Biden making history but not in a good
way surging gas prices and higher rents
pushing inflation to a 40-year high
prices are up 8.5 percent just from a
year ago making it the fastest bike in
more than four decades as usual here's
the president though trying to pin the
blame on Vlad
Putin's invasion of Ukraine has driven
up gas prices and food prices all over
the world we saw today's inflation data
70 percent of the increase in prices in
March came from Putin's price hike in
gasoline I'm doing everything within my
power by executive orders to bring down
the price and address the Putin price
item in fact we've already made progress
since March inflation data was collected
your family budget your ability to fill
up your tank none of it should hinge on
whether a dictator declares war and
commits genocide in a half a world away
to help deal with this Putin price hike
nice try Joe but the numbers tell a very
different story prices have been on the
rise since President Biden took office
long before Putin launched his invasion
and even the left-wing media doesn't buy
it watch
I think there's this whole idea oh the
White House is just losing the messaging
War you know if only they knew how good
the job situation was but if you ask
Americans why do you think the economy
is bad it's inflation the voters know
exactly what's going on they're not
stupid they're not stupid do you know I
think that also the Putin price hike
like it's you know like when somebody
tries too hard yeah and it's just like
Fringe
you grant and I feel like The Prudent
price like people know what's going on
they know the price has been going up
for a long time they can appreciate the
fact that there was a supply chain
crisis and they all but they also know
what happened on Energy prices as well
and that the signals that were sent to
to that industry look the darling of the
midterm election ads is not going to be
Donald Trump it's not going to be Nancy
Pelosi it's going to be these Obama
economists who are coming out and saying
the Obama alums running the economy for
President Biden have it all wrong and
you can just Those ads cut themselves
right now uh
the media also I don't know guys have
you noticed that they're trying to help
the Democrats so much right now all
these articles are like midterm is going
to be really bad Democrats better pay
attention wow it could be even worse
than they think and you see it all
everywhere they're trying to send
signals like you got to do more and I
don't think Putin price hikes is going
to cut it is uh the Putin price hike
going to cut it Harold or they I think
they need to change the message so
there's no doubt the the polling data
we've seen inflation is what Small
Business Leaders uh from all the polling
data from the nfib and other business
organizations whether you think it's
inflation this is what people believe
and you can't fight that which I think
is what you're saying to they do have to
tell a better story but they need to
tell a better story with answers my uh
introduction to politics and orientation
to this day remains I like all the
Hoople and the noise and all you got to
have people doing it but then you got to
figure out how you solve it and if I'm
in the white house I do what I've been
saying now for a few weeks there's a
tremendous amount of money that we
approach the country appropriated to
deal with covet now just a step back for
a moment gas prices are up because of
reporting they've been going to before
but there's no doubt when you impose
sanctions on a huge producer of gas and
oil whatever the thing is it's gonna
it's gonna cause prices to go up they're
the biggest producers of wheat things
are going to go up if they're sanctions
on that country Shanghai is shut down
because of cobit that we can quarrel
with whether Shanghai should have done
that but that's what's happening so
you're saying blame China in Russia
I'm just only being a realist so about
what now now we all know this is he's
not the first president to play politics
I mean all politicians play Politics the
best ones win at it the question is will
he be able to convince the American
people
but but he's not he's not winning this
argument right now if I were them I'd
repurpose money that was spent for covet
to help small business people and middle
class families I would tighten the
thresholds the qualification thresholds
to ensure that you got one person's vote
in the Senate you know who that is Joe
I'd have him at this I'd have him at the
White House with me saying Joe let's you
want to be number one Joe and me number
two Joe I'll accept that but I want the
best answers for West Virginians and the
rest of the country I think short of
doing that Democrats are going to
continue to face polls like this and we
could find ourselves I'm a Democrat we
could find ourselves in a in a really
bad electoral position come November and
frankly we would deserve it does do you
feel proud when you say you're a
Democrat
[Laughter]
okay here's here's the bottom line Joe
Biden can't get out of his own way okay
you think Joe Biden is going to change
the message it's all about Putin it's
all about Putin it's all about Putin
that's all he knows to say and the
American people are smarter than that
they saw gas prices go up before Putin
and by the way a lot of these the the
sanctions don't go into effect until
June 24th who are we kidding and and Joe
but Joe has an answer for it here's the
good news he's going to make sure he's
going to suspend the ban on higher
ethanol gasoline to lower prices which
amounts to Pennies on the gallon so
that's that's his resolution Joe Biden
deserves what he's getting because he
has been so woke and so focused on the
left that he hasn't been listening to
the American people but how could he
listen to the American people he doesn't
know what he's doing and the problem
here going forward is he's bringing
everyone down with him this is April he
doesn't have the time to do it and by
the way he was running to Iowa today and
apparently the the front runner uh in
for in Iowa didn't didn't manage to get
the sufficient numbers to qualify for
the primary that the guy that he's
supporting I mean they're just a mess
the whole thing is a mess so take you
know when it's your fault take the
burden and deal with it but he can't
because he's incompetent Greg the judge
makes a good point if you just listen to
the American people in the spring in the
summer in the fall that were kind of
people getting upset about inflation
instead of listening to his advisors who
are saying yeah you know it'll go away
he might have been ahead of this a
little bit you don't have to listen to
the American people when you have
pollsters remember nothing no problem
exists until the pollster tells you it's
true right I don't know what's worse
having CNN poop on you or a bird well
you saw them that video you saw a big
pile of bird crap on on by the shoulder
followed by CNN and I couldn't tell
which was which was more damaging but uh
when um uh I know Harold you're a
politician but when you say play
politics it's a nice way of saying lying
through your teeth and oh and the Putin
price hike is a lie it's a lie and it's
because it's it's an effort to
instead of solving the actual suffering
solving the messaging and I think if
they when you were talking about the
overkill it's like they're tackling the
messaging and first rather than the
actual problem and that's what really
pisses people off and it makes you
wonder like why do we have inflation why
do we have crime why do we have
homelessness why do we have so much
mental illness so much malaise it's
because it's about the messaging and not
the suffering uh why do the Democrats
progressives really need places like the
Washington Post and and to a larger
extent Twitter why do they need Twitter
in their pocket it's a key to their
survival because in terms of preserving
their power you have to hide their
outcomes their consequences the results
of their of their policies uh think of
how the media was able to cover for the
riots uh the hunter laptop
um mental illness which is Raging across
this country and has gotten worse it's
because the media helps cover it up so
you don't see these outcomes the problem
with inflation you can see the the
outcome you just walk into the
supermarket and you look at a at a half
a pound of steak and it's now more than
a pound of steak was two months ago you
this is something you can't hide that's
why they're going to lose if the Red
Wave isn't like a red wedding uh there's
no hope for the Republicans they should
everybody should win even if they have
bad candidates even if the Republicans
have their typical really bad wacky
candidates they're gonna win too May the
wackiest cabinets
the other thing that Biden could do that
would actually be a little bit more
believable and like is why don't they
blame the FED I would be in Powell like
every single day of the week so you like
that politics
that's the truth pal should have raised
rates last year
it's good luck and that means he's in
for some good luck can't get any worse
well you know what it could have landed
it on his head so it landed on his
shoulder so what does that tell you well
he's got some good luck oh you know all
right no sniffing that hair it's true
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else